Here's a skydiver with the force of mg down and here's the earth with the force of mg up.
This mg is the exact same size as this mg.
So we want to use the mass of the skydiver, 65 kg.
When we plug in 65 and 10 for g, we find this at 650 N.
Now what acceleration does that correspond to?
If we want to calculate the acceleration of the earth, let's use F = ma.
This is the mass of the earth by the way with subscript e.
If  we want to calculate the acceleration of the earth, we should use F = ma.
And now, this mass is the mass of the earth and our mass is 6x10²⁴.
If I divide both sides by this mass, I get an acceleration of 1.1x10⁻²² m/s².
If I use our tried and true motion equation, assume that the earth's initial velocity upward is 0
and plug in for a and t, I get an answer of 2x10⁻¹⁷ m.
This is way smaller than even a single atom.
So yes, even though they're equal and opposite forces, the earth is so massive
that the force any individual person exerts on it is totally negligible.